so what we're trying to do is expand our
understanding of sets of how to how to
talk about them in particular okay
because just like just like in normal
language right for instance we have
words like say yeah you call when we
talk in normal language we say this
language is fine it's good but we we
sort of take words like this and we can
track them and we say things like this
we invent a new word right because
expanding our language by taking other
things right it helps us to communicate
faster and more efficiently okay so
that's kind of what we're going to do
today
well startups that have a nice and
gently okay if you see something like
this right hey a set and you've got an
okay and that's how I read that okay
this is this is the number of objects in
set a or if you like it's the set size
so this is the size of set okay now so
far through this topic we've sort of
always been starting from scratch and
said okay there's a universal set let me
tell you what numbers I'm interested in
and then I'll say this is said hey this
is set B and it's in some ways
completely arbitrary right but there are
some sets that come up over and over
again just like the phrase you are comes
up with say hundreds of times a day so
it makes sense to have like a shorthand
way to say okay so I'm gonna tell you
that some important sets so something
important
since okay now there's an order to this
I'll try and do it right in my head all
of these sets because they're special
and we want to recognize them rather
than just using letters to do them
it's a see how this is a special view
and when you see it like our Universal
set
so these extra dashes come up a lot
if you see an end right but it's got an
extra line in them like that okay so n
stands for the natural numbers okay now
I would love to give you a completely
unambiguous definition all over the
natural numbers the problem is there
isn't one okay so I'll give you the two
definitions and you might be able to
think of why they're equally to write
the natural numbers who would like to
give suggestion what do you think the
natural numbers are all the numbers that
exists in nature what kinds of can you
give me some examples one two three four
okay now you see the other name for
natural numbers is the counting numbers
but I'm avoiding that very deliberately
you'll see why in a second
one of the classic ways to define the
net four numbers is to make it this set
one two three four and so on forever
okay
these are the counseling on this
unambiguously right but some people say
hey you know what you're kind of missing
one of the most important numbers in
there maybe the most important number
which is well what happens when you're
counting but there aren't any there and
the answer is that's at zero right so
that's kind of a notable absence from
this list okay
here's the problem I can't avoid the
language of natural numbers it's
important half the world meet this when
they send out four numbers and the other
half of the world is that there's no
consensus whatsoever um some people to
make sure it's really really unambiguous
they'll call this one and then they'll
put a little subscript zero next to it
right n 0 or n naught okay and that
means you definitely have to include
zero but sometimes goes either way right
but nonetheless very important for seven
others yes
yeah yeah he's the thing zero ruins
things sometimes but not all the time
right
so depending on where you are that's why
some people use one or the other
now let's go from there to a far more
actually the rest of the sets aren't
completely under because the next one is
is it okay now let's wait what's in
stands for a second it's very familiar
it's a set of integers right now how how
are the integers different from the
natural numbers what did the integers
include but the natural numbers don't
have and the answer is or obviously
these are whole numbers but I don't have
any negatives here do i right zero is
not negative he's special
okay um integers add in the negative
okay now the reason why it's said is
that's a reference to it's a reference
to a German word za which which has to
do with counting and wholeness okay uh
and that's kind of it's a tip of the hat
to the fact that Germans did a lot of
incredible mathematics and a lot of
development in this field can understand
you like what's the understand well a
lot we'll get to that a bit later on
okay now there are two subsets subsets
we know what that means
all the integers very simple ones yeah
the positives is n plus right and that's
a that's a superscript above and Z minus
oh geez that that's in a different kind
of you see if you're talking about
limits you can't approach a set because
it's like which part of it are you
approaching right so this means positive
sorry Nikki I'll just wait for the rest
of the class it's just a bit sad when
you have to do this in a class where
people choose to be here
these are all still whole numbers okay
which then raises the question well what
about the numbers that are toll okay now
I wonder what you would call as the
letter that you would put for the next
set now we're kind of we kind of try to
expand our horizon ability for families
of numbers okay Brenda are you gonna
suggest something or was the question
or is it is yes no that's right that's
right
so it's a bit funny isn't it if if
that's exactly right
if Zed was your Universal set then these
two are not complements because they're
both missing zero right so zero would be
yeah it's outside zero always see you
would be in this camp obviously zooms
always ruining things